somebody who just came off of his
training camp tour
uh writing for the ringer his stuff is
always deep and fun and funny and also
informative back here on the rich eisen
show kevin clark of the ringer how are
you sir
i'm doing great i'm a little tired but
when it's all football it's energizing
you're unable kevin to say to a 52 year
old family a man or a father of three
who does a three hour show every day
you may not say those words with a head
of hair like you have okay kevin
but i understand everybody's got their
own beat that they've got a drum i get
it
uh who have you who'd you speak to you
seem like you spoke to every year yeah
everybody uh on your tour
before great i mean i i think things are
back to normal people are excited about
football and excited to talk about
football so um talk to most the people
that that i wanted to um joe burrow most
recently patrick mahomes for that uh
aaron rodgers uh josh allen and
talk to them just about different things
you know i asked josh allen what the
lessons were of his rise and and if he's
telling a gm or a coach in in five years
what that what he learned about
quarterbacking it'd be that um you know
with aaron it's a little more pop
culture tv stuff but i think the
overarching theme is everybody's back
and happy to be at it okay so um it was
mostly just pop culture tv stuff with
aaron not much football to talk about i
mean we we just talked about life stuff
and we talked about you know simone
biles is obviously the headline at that
point right we talked a lot about um he
he was extremely proud of simone and her
her courage to say i'm scared and i
shouldn't be out there this is the way
he put it um and i think that aaron is
in a really good place and i think rich
the the the good thing that they did is
everything's out there now in green bed
aaron said everything there is to say
brian guten kuhn said everything there
is to say matt lafleur has made his
feelings known to her now when aaron
talks to the media it's almost like
they're past it rich because we know
what we know what's going to happen we
know you know uh aaron talked to peter
came the other day about this but
everybody's stance is known
and so it's almost like at this point
everybody's in a strangely good place
but what's the stance you know what i'm
saying kevin like what's the stance the
stance has got to be we'll take the
temperature of everybody you know next
february and hopefully the temperature
will be like 20 degrees on a parade you
know what i mean like so that's that's
the way you've got to play it like there
you can't sit here and say
definitely rogers last year it's it's
jordan loves time absolutely you can't
you can't say that right now i mean in
the same way that you can't
say the the the exact opposite that that
if it all does go great rogers is
absolutely staying and they they won't
stick to their time
line with love like we just don't know
let's just go play football that's
that's where we currently are in that
world right you say yeah no that that
that's the stance is that they're going
to take the temperature seven months
from now whatever it is and they'll
figure it out i mean i think if we're if
we were all betting men we would guess
if there's going to be aaron rodgers
last year um he's made it known what he
was unhappy about and the parts of the
communication process that he felt was
broken down um and i think that if it's
a bad year for everybody aaron's
probably going to move on if it's a good
year then we'll see if it ends in the
nfc championship game again i would
trend towards aaron not coming back if
it ends in the super bowl i would trend
towards him coming back i mean i just
think that there's so many questions
here i mean what's the market for aaron
rodgers in february in march if he has a
year like he had last year and he won
the mvp yeah there's going to be 20 bids
there's going to be first round picks
all over the place being thrown at the
packers um what if he just has an okay
here i mean there's question marks about
that what if his options aren't as good
as we would think you just don't know i
mean that's the thing about the nfl is
that the narrative can change so quickly
rich that i think to say we know what's
going to happen on february 20th or
march 15th it's crazy i just think
everybody knows where they stand from an
emotional standpoint and we'll see what
happens and then just i guess last one
based on you having boots on the ground
there and you know i know you spoke life
stuff with him we we used to have an
annual standing interview with him
solely about game of thrones that was
the
that was honestly we would call him up
and the packers up and say we want 15
minutes with him nothing but game of
thrones we will not talk football with
him so i totally understand
that but boots on the ground what did
happen best you can tell
to get this seven month grace period
comfort zone where we'll all figure it
out feel it out we'll take the
temperature at the end of it
that we thought during the from the
draft all the way up to that moment that
rogers returned thought that rogers
would never grant that extra space
to the packers what happened to give
rogers the comfort level to say yes to
that best you can tell there's a couple
things you know i did talk to brian
gutenkins
about that in the journey and what's
interesting i think in generalities
first of all they have a very good
football team and they have devante
adams they have david boxier who i know
is coming on after this yes and so i i
think that there's
there's
you're gonna win
in green bay where you might not win in
wherever if david pepper wanted to throw
a bunch of first round picks in carolina
in denver whatever you know what you
have but also i would say that the nfl
is very limiting for superstars i mean
look at the franchise tag look at how
long aaron rodgers contract was
look at the fact that brian gutenko said
that on draft night they only got one or
two calls one of the things in san
francisco who are obviously out of that
market and so i think it was a mixture
of a he they knew they could win this
year everybody that could win this year
have kind of a last dance style thing
with davonte adams and the fact that i
just don't think he had a ton of options
i mean i i he had a bunch of years left
two years left his contract you can
franchise tag a guy what three times um
in his situation and so i i just don't
think there was a lot of wiggle room and
so i think he knew coming back getting
the promise to quote review his
situation at the end of the year that
was about as well as he was gonna get as
good as he was going to get without
retiring and i don't think he wanted to
do that he still loves football well
that's clear and he loves his teammates
i mean there's no
he just you know you could see that and
um kevin clark of the ringer here on the
rich eisen show the takeaway from your
chat with patrick mahomes is what
so i wanted to know what patrick mahomes
saw he said that he had watched the
super bowl twice um and not for
motivation but for education
so i said what'd you say and he took a
lot of the he didn't take a lot of the
blame but he took
he saw floss in his game and i think a
lot of people rich a lot of quarterbacks
would look at that game and say i was
under pressure the whole game there's
nothing i could have done and it was
interesting for him to break down to me
what he saw he saw that he thought that
he got hit so early and so often that he
stops making his reads and then
it kind of devolved from there he said
that there were clean pockets he would
see
where he started running and seeing
ghosts basically paraphrasing the ghost
part but he started running from clean
pockets just because he'd been getting
hit so early in the game and so hard in
the game
so what he's working on now he's
studying tape of aaron rodgers he's
studying tape of tom brady to see how
they operate in the pocket because he
wants to play uh a more i guess
disciplined is the way he put it game
where he's going to stand in the pocket
and dice you up where he only uses his
legs in a scrambling as a last resort
and i think that he feels and there's
something he admitted to he feels that
sometimes he defaults to using his legs
and trying to make things happen when
that should be the second or third
option and so he's trying to change his
game he said that aaron rodgers is a
model because aaron used to do exactly
what he did and then he started playing
a lot more from the pocket and so a lot
of film study of aaron um some film
study of tom brady because of what he
does in the pocket but
mahomes not trying to overhaul his game
entirely but there's tweaks he thinks he
can that he can do to make himself
better and i think if you're in the afc
west right now that's exactly what you
don't want to read is that he's trying
to uh improve himself that's a dangerous
quarterback man
well because but because
hearing him say that he's watched that
film yeah and he takes away what he
didn't do right
and then the general manager in brett
vich we've had on this program
said that he said the night of the super
bowl i've got to deal with this
offensive line and boy howdy did he ever
do that
put it all together with the returning
cast and andy reed and and travis kelsey
with his drawn on beard and everybody
still
having the same attitude that's a
dangerous combination in the afc
without a doubt without a doubt i mean
and when you're there you realize it i
mean you see rich you've been to a lot
of nfl practices
you see an efficiency there where they
just get their job done there's never
any training camp fights there's not any
motivational mumbo jumbo where they're
trying to build a culture whatever
they're installing their plays they're
running it perfectly and they're getting
on with their day and getting onto
meetings and that's what i find so
amazing about andy reid and how
efficient and dangerous this team is and
i think brett beach going out and
there's not a lot i think people think
that what bret beach did was easy it's
not to go out and trade a first round
pick for orlando brown um to get joe
tooney to overhaul to to use the draft
to get crete humphrey and trey smith i
mean i just think that there are there
are not 32 general managers 31 other
general managers who would have picked
it fix it that quickly and that's what i
find so interesting and i kind of feel
like brett beach rich is the perfect gm
for mahomes because if there's a problem
over the next 10 years of that deal he's
gonna fix it that's what he does he'll
make anything fit under the salary cap
with his cap guru grant tillis and i
just think going forward whenever you
see a shortcoming on that kansas city
roster it's going to be filled because
of the combination of of beach and andy
reed and and then that front office and
then the mistakes that patrick mahomes
overcomes whether or not it's with the
line or the skill guys i mean obviously
you can't have a repeat of what you had
uh against tampa in tampa but as long as
everything is just okay mahomes will
make it great
uh kevin clark of the ringer here on the
rich eisen show so we just talked about
the chiefs and
everybody i think still believes the
bills are are the team that's closest
still
um alan has been paid did you speak to
him after he had been paid or before he
had just before so so he didn't uh i
didn't i didn't get to ask him for any
money all right
so so uh what what else what did you
glean
from yeah from that
trip i'm totally comfortable in again
almost like my home totally comfortable
admitting
where he needed to grow i mean i he was
very open and honest about his struggles
early on in his career and what he did
to get better from that and i kind of
think that
is similar to the kansas city it's an
organizational trial because what they
did when i don't think people realize
this when josh allen was a rookie
the bills were were using the most dead
money dead salary cap money in the
history of football they were paying all
these guys marcel darius tyrod taylor
all of these guys not to play and so
josh allen sitting there behind a
terrible offensive line no skill guys
they go out and they build the offensive
line around him they get him weapons the
next year they they they take the big
swing and they get stefan diggs and i
kind of think this is the model going
forward and if you're a if you're a
young quarterback you want an
organization to operate like the bills
and josh allen was very very upfront
about that and one of the things is i
think that he views this season as very
special you know he said look they built
the line and year two for me they got me
the skill guys in your three he said
it's year four it's go time and i think
we know what that means and i kind of
think last year taking a leap by the way
in the cove year in general is amazing
because of the lack of you know i i
heard from a coach there was saying that
they were just trying to replicate you
know in-person meetings they've got
these guys on speakerphone moving around
rooms and stuff but it just wasn't the
same
and
to take a leap like that from year two
to year three was amazing to begin with
i think everyone there is much more
comfortable now they get a full training
camp they get to see each other they get
to gel have that chemistry so i think
that everybody there is is excited about
this year maybe even more so than last
year did you get to take a look at cole
beasley's plexiglas situation or that is
that i mix that one up not see the
plexiglas i also i was in minnesota i
did not see the uh kirk cousins flexing
glass either he wasn't walking around
with it they weren't walking around with
that coal
okay not in a bubble just yet um but i'm
sure i'm sure that's coming it was was
cole talking about uh not taking the vax
with his nose sticking out over his mask
did you see that
rich i want to be delicate here but i
kept my distance
i'm being in delicate i don't mean to
pull you into my in delicateness i
decided to uh i decided to stay six feet
away from cole beasley so what did you
what did you get what did you figure out
from burro what what are we going to see
from him yeah what because no one's
talking about the bengals zero nobody
0.0 and it's unbelievable because this
is a guy who 19 months ago had the best
college season of all time uh
efficiency-wise he was maybe the coolest
looking quarterback of all time when
he's chomping on a cigar after the
national championship game and
i i talked to him first of all he's a
very blunt and honest person and and i i
was excited to to hear about that there
were some dark times for him he
basically said you know he went from as
we said national champion hugely famous
college quarterback to nine months later
he couldn't go to the bathroom without
somebody helping him and moving his legs
basically um and so there was some
soul-searching that went on there but i
also think that there's
i think they know what he's good at and
so one of the interesting things that
brian callahan the oc there in
cincinnati told me was hey they're
letting him run some of the meetings
there the offensive meetings and they
want him to get ideally and callahan was
a former broncos assistant they want him
to get into peyton manning mode which
means his vision is so good burrows
vision is so good and he's able to get
five guys out into a route and diagnose
it they want him to be able to get to
the mode where he's at the line of
scrimmage basically changing all the
plays up to where it's his offense and
with boro that's the kind of that's the
kind of
offense you can do because he's so good
at processing i say the drawback is
burro told me he wants five guys out
into a round which is not necessarily
normal in the nfl but also he's trying
to get healthy rich and so you want as
much protection as possible so there's a
push and a pull there and there's i
think a little bit of wrestling with
that and grappling with that where do we
get all these guys out in a route so bro
can be burrow or do we keep some guys
into blocks because we don't want them
to hit get hit at all so i think that
the answer is going to be get those guys
into a route but he's got to throw it
very quickly i think that burrow still
has the capability to show us this year
he's on the superstar track because i
don't think that team's good enough to
win nine 10 11 games i am
i i i don't i don't think that that
that's that's like necessarily going to
happen right what i am saying is is that
we can see he's on that superstar track
they go eight and nine and we feel good
about 20 22. well i think that there's
still some team building huge team
building issues that not even borough
can overcome well i'll tell you what man
i mean before he got hurt he was getting
his ass kicked and he was still
performing very well i mean he really
was and that was
other than the fact that you know
you blow your knee out it's obviously a
shame but to have a season cut short
when when he he was taking the the lumps
that's what we keep talking about should
the bears start justin fields or not you
know and yes you take your lumps and you
go and you take your lumps and the lumps
eventually
allow you to progress faster most likely
than the other and he didn't have that
and that's the conversation we're going
to hear about the bears and justin
fields and andy dalton who says it's his
time and like he's going to say anything
else
you know but it's it's it's right for
him to say that because what are you
going to say i
man i mean we could literally go on and
on and on about all 32 right now but um
you do a great job
kevin thank you so much thank you so
much
i appreciate you saying that um
i could literally talk to you for the
whole hour but i know you got to go
so uh let's do this again is there is
there one other thing that you you
gleaned
last thing anything that you you take
away that you haven't given to the
audience here a good story a good thing
somebody that we're overlooking what do
you what do you got for me on that front
wow i would say i have not written this
yet but i spent some time with dan
campbell
and i really enjoyed being in his
presence i think he's a perfect coach
for that team do i think dan campbell
would work with green bay and aaron
rodgers right now no i don't but i do
think he's the kind of guy that can
change a culture
and understands what motivates the sort
of rank and file nfl player because he's
been there
so i'm
higher on dan campbell than most people
and i also think that one thing you need
to know about dan campbell
he does not care how things play to the
media he cares how
things play to his players and maybe the
fans
the biting kneecap stuff that was just
for the players and the fan base that
was not for you and i rich and that to
me was a really interesting conversation
to have
i was going to ask you if you're being
nice about dan campbell because you
value your kneecaps literally that was
my follow-up to that hey i spent 45
minutes with him my kneecaps are still
intact
ladies and gentlemen that's the update
there you go that's the headline uh
kevin thank you very much let's do this
as much as you'd like because i i i
enjoy the chats thank you you take any
time you got to read this man's material
kevin clark
on the ringer uh at the ringer
uh it's at by kevin clark on twitter
follow him i do you can read all his
terrific material
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here